as viruses multiply they change and the
same is happening to the corona virus
all viruses mutate and and that is to be
expected scientists have been tracking
those mutations while following
coronaviruses journey around the world
some of the mutations help the virus to
spread others do nothing at all but as
corona virus multiplies and changes
could it also become more deadly this is
your covert 19 special here on DW I'm
Chris Cobra welcome to the program
the corona virus is not the same that
came out of China half a year ago like
other viruses it has mutated and a
recent study suggests the globally
predominant strain is more infectious
than the original the new corona virus
like all other viruses is constantly
mutating as it replicates inside its
human host the virus uses us to multiply
by injecting its genetic information
into our cells the cell then becomes a
kind of virus factory mass producing the
genetic material that allows more of the
virus to develop as the virus replicates
mistakes are often made errors mean the
genetic material changes causing a
mutated version of the virus if those
changes are advantageous the mutation
will go on to spread
funny Massimo SARS Cove too doesn't have
here to mutate as easily as other
viruses like influenza for example some
experts say it doesn't have to because
thus far it's been so successful
nevertheless the mutation could take
place that might hit humans much harder
than previous versions of the virus of
course it would be an evolutionary
disadvantage if as a virus my host died
while I was trying to replicate the most
successful viruses are those that show
no symptoms to begin with allowing them
to spread before taking down their host
if a more aggressive mutation of
coronavirus were already spreading it
might be hard to spot that would require
very complex testing in a lab it would
have to be done very precisely to be
able to answer questions like is this
form more infectious can the immune
system deal with it better such studies
take a lot of time one major change in
the virus has apparently already been
determined earlier generations of
coronavirus replicated in the lungs a
new mutations using host cells somewhere
else in the body the throat more
contagious if not more deadly so what
does that mean for the search for a
vaccine our researchers struggling to
keep up with an ever-changing virus
as as Congrats double fun it completely
depends on how this vaccine is designed
whether it does end up offering a broad
immune response the virus would have a
tougher time quickly getting around a
vaccine with the wide-reaching and very
effective immune response it seems we
may not need a new vaccine for every new
year like with influenza that's at least
the hope we have for the coming years
with every new patient emerging immune
after surviving cough in nineteen
pressure piles on coronavirus to change
as it does scientists will have to keep
up earlier I spoke to dr. andreas bacala
of the Research Center for molecular
medicine of the austrian academy of
sciences and as there are now multiple
versions of the corona virus i asked
them if their characteristics were
vastly different there are hundreds of
different mutations and and this is a
totally natural and normal process
because these RNA viruses they have an
imperfect replication of their own
genome so per se just finding mutations
is nothing bad or good this is just how
nature works okay
lab research shows that the globally
dominating version of the corona virus
transmits more easily between humans now
than the original did does that mean
it's also more dangerous no it does not
mean that it's more dangerous you're
referring to one particular mutation
that has been in the media over the last
few weeks and it's known by researchers
for months already
it's called D 614 gene mutation and it
yes it is a prevalent mutation that is
found pretty much all over the globe by
now and also by now scientists have
actually obtained evidence in the lab in
vitro that this mutation might lead to
higher infectivity again in vitro but
what it actually means in a human to
human transmission scenario and for the
pandemic is still something researchers
need to work out so it transmits more
easily does that mean it's less
contagious less lethal
I think at the moment there is very
little evidence that it effects the
clinical course of infection the only
thing I guess that is more or less hard
evidence is that patients who have this
virus with this given mutation tend to
have a higher viral load and high viral
load could translate into higher
transmissibility but the actual proof
for this is still missing and out there
hmm
other ways to predict how viruses are
likely to mutate that's a difficult one
I think it's easier to look backward
retrospectively and I think these
mutation landscapes that we have
basically identified in the past have
been a wonderful tool to look back in
history where does the virus come from
and tracking its history right but
looking in a more prospective future
forward-looking perspective this is
nothing more difficult and this has to
do with the fact that mutations occur
randomly and it depends on the context
whether they might confer an advantage
to the virus or not so in that sense I
think you cannot predict exactly which
will be the next mutations coming up yet
the mutation that we have already
actually tell us a lot about the history
of the virus now as the novel
coronavirus has changed has mutated over
the last couple of months what does that
mean for the development of a vaccine of
course one may be needs to explain that
the vaccine is usually working by means
of antibodies or also by another immune
cell called t-cells and those immune
cells and antibodies they recognize
specific regions are in the virus in the
proteins of the virus and so if these
proteins would mutate away it and
potentially the target is gone and the
vaccine would not be working anymore
however what is important to to make
clear is that a vaccine never has only
one target but it has multiple targets
tens or hundreds of targets and in this
regard I think it's extremely unlikely
that one or few mutations on the virus
ID would render a vaccine effect less
and less spectral a member of the
Research Center for molecular medicine
of the
Austrian Academy of Sciences thank you
for your insights and next up is Derrick
Williams he's our science correspondent
and has been hard at work answering your
questions about kovat 19 here's our
latest installment have any researchers
tried ivermectin I talked about this a
couple of months ago but in light of
recent developments I thought it would
be good to discuss it again health
officials in some countries particularly
in in South America have been promoting
the anti-parasitic drug ivermectin as a
treatment for kovat 19and and people
have been buying up supplies of it even
though there's no solid evidence that
the medication works against the new
coronavirus ivermectin is however a very
effective treatment for infestations of
of nasty things like like lice and and
pin worms one big problem now is that
with stocks that the drugs used to treat
humans depleted people are beginning to
self dose with versions of the drug that
are usually prescribed for animals now
it should be obvious why that's a very
bad idea there are human trials going on
and at least one has been concluded but
the first results don't really look very
convincing um until we know a lot more
the WH o is not recommending ivermectin
for anything but what it was developed
for which is parasite infestations how
different is SARS Cove to two other
viruses that infect us for example do
people who catch influenza sometimes
have no symptoms yes although
asymptomatic is a is a pretty squishy
term we've known for decades that people
who don't report flu symptoms can test
positive as carriers for the bug and and
older estimates usually put the number
of asymptomatic carriers for flu at
around 50% a much site
British study from 2014 however
determined an even larger number of
people infected with influenza never
develop symptoms 77% to be exact
now if that's correct it means not even
one in four people who catch the flu
will ever show any signs of it one way
or the other even if the estimates don't
all agree there's plenty of evidence
showing that it's quite common for us to
catch a range of other viruses and show
no signs of illness and and there's also
broad agreement that those asymptomatic
carriers are likely contributing
significantly to the spread of those
diseases and of course you can post your
questions to Derek on our YouTube
channel and if you'd like to keep up
with the latest developments on the
corona virus pandemic do subscribe to
our newsletter just log on to DWM slash
corona - newsletter and finally it's
back to school for 6 million students in
Seoul after a kovat 19 emergency in the
South Korean capital schools reopened
with many changes though face masks of
course are now a must for teachers and
students even on the soccer field
temperature checks are now a daily
experience anyone whose temperature
exceeds 37 point 5 degrees Celsius is
sent home students are also divided into
rotations meaning that some stay at home
where they take virtual classes South
Korea was the first Asian country to
reopen schools after a corona lockdown
in May